first of all guys i i couldn't help but
think about how like charming and funny
chicky was in this film
knowing that he's a real guy that went
in this crazy crazy mission how did you
decide how you wanted to play him how
you want to portray him
you know a lot of that was written
written for me there was there was
uh great guys it was
you know it's tricky such a magic magic
uh person and his personality is larger
than life i mean
you get that sense when you meet him and
talk to him and
um
it comes across in the way that he was
able to
even think of beginning this ridiculous
of a
journey and to actually pull it off it
takes sort of a magic individual and so
it was really fun to work with pete and
kind of find him and discover him along
the way i knew he would be a good fit
for this you know he he's
he's
i think his performance here is
incredible it reminds me of travolta in
saturday night fever like he's a flawed
character who's you know this person is
a flawed character who makes mistakes
but he's always trying to improve his
heart's in the right place and he's easy
to root for and he's really really good
looking
so uh
it was uh easy to like him yeah you know
there's a the line in there that bill
murray says you know war is not a tv
show right in 2022 we're very accustomed
to it being a tv show kind of yeah right
but back then it wouldn't have been
so
common to see it on screen what's your
id what's your take on the whole thing
that now we watch these conflicts and
because you know we see them so often
maybe they kind of just disappear in the
background well you know actually in in
the 1960s they were showing it on tv a
lot more after the you know when they
went to iraq they stopped showing
like they wouldn't allow
them filming the bodies coming off the
planes in the united states so it's like
when i was growing up
uh as a little kid you see my father
watching the news and i'd see you know
blood and guts all over the place we
were actually seeing more uh but it is
it is uh
there's something um
i don't know which way is right i think
honestly i think the more you actually
see of what's happening um the less
you're going to there people are going
to want to get into a war i think when
you hide wars by not letting them film
the reality of it it actually
it it hurts us as a people and that's
one of the two lines that cheeky
discovers in this right absolutely yeah
yeah definitely um can you talk to me
about getting bill on board for this
yeah because he's notoriously kind of
difficult to get a hold of yeah are you
like the guy that has his number i have
his 800 number and you know you call you
leave a message and i know when i call
him he will call me back within a month
and uh but uh yeah bill bill's bill he
has no assistance he has no you know
manager no agent he just does his own
thing but uh it it is a honor to work
with them because
like russell crowe when they're on the
set bill murray russell crowe elevates
the whole movie the crew
the actors
and it makes you it gives you this
confidence like wow this could be a
really good movie look who we have in it
uh and it just really it really helped
us
definitely is there a uh a version of
this for you in real life have you ever
done something that people thought was
like this is crazy man you can't do this
and you're like
no i'm gonna do it
um not this not quite this crazy yeah
the chickies takes the cake man he's
this is one of the wildest and i mean
we've i've had
lots of good ideas when i'm drunk and i
i usually don't follow through with them
or in some happy way it might be off but
nothing with this i think getting into
the business and that that was like that
yeah it felt like stoop you're like what
he was like what's wrong with you that's
that that's the dumbest thing i've ever
heard that's actually really really
that's it in general yeah jen's
congratulations on the film thank you
very much
you